okay welcome back so up until now we've
talked about this linear system of
equations X dot equals ax plus bu and we
have some conditions on when this is
controllable so namely we build this
controllability matrix here and we make
sure that this has n linearly
independent columns where n is the
dimension of my state space and if this
thing has a rank of n then my system is
controllable and that means a lot of
things that means that I can steer X to
any vector in RN I can arbitrarily place
the eigenvalues of this closed-loop
system to anywhere I want but I haven't
really shown you why the system is
controllable why all of those things are
true if this is full rank ok and so
there's a few things I'm going to do I'm
you know this is not meant to be an
exhaustive class on controls and so if
you were taking the full control class
I'd expect people to prove the
controllability I just want to give you
an intuition for what is true when and
how to use it but to understand this a
little better I like to think about this
in discrete time XK plus 1 equals ax k
plus B u K now remember this a and this
B are not the same as this a and this B
these are my discrete time matrices if I
was going to be really careful I might
put like a tilde or a hat on these but
that's going to take a lot of time so
I'm just going to write it out like this
and then what I want to do is I want to
write down the impulse response so the
impulse response which essentially means
I'm going to kick the system in the U
direction and let's just assume that U
is a single input channel so like a
scalar u we're going to kick the system
in in U and then we're going to measure
what happens to X we're going to let
that impulse ring through the system ok
so we're going to have U at time 0
equals 1 so we're going to impulse U at
time sorry at time 0 and then for all
later times we're just going to let it
equal 0 so u 1 equals 0 u 2 equals 0 u 3
equals 0 dot dot down to you
M equals zero okay so this is an
impulsive and impulse in the input and
then what I'm going to do is I'm going
to measure how that rings through the
system okay so I'm also going to start
with an initial condition X naught of
zero okay and so at x at x 0 is 0 and u
at x 0 is 1 then X at time 1 is just B
times 1 so X 1 is just B it's the vector
B so this is an impulse in U is a lot
like an initial condition in the B
direction ok then at time 2 X at time 2
is just a of X at time 1 so X at time 2
is just a times X at time 1 which is B
so I get ax 2 equals a B X 3 is just a
times X 2 X 3 is just a times X 2 so
it's a squared B and so on and so forth
so all the way down here at X M this
equals a to the M minus 1 times B ok and
so this should at least give you some
intuition for for why this is an
important matrix or at least this
subspace if this subspace generated by a
and B is interesting because at least in
discrete time if I give the system a
kick so let's say I have a physical
system like my pendulum you know maybe
hanging down and I literally hit it with
a hammer so I excite that thing and I
see how it moves I want to know that
this input rings through the system and
touches every state in RN ok if I hit my
system with an impulse in U and it rings
through the system and there are some
directions and state space that are not
touched by that B input then there's no
way I can possibly reach them with
control ok there will be some states in
RN that are just not controllable
they'll be perpendicular to the space
that can be hit with control so somehow
this is the space that control can
affect
and there's some linear algebra that I'm
glossing over but basically I just have
to look at the first n minus one of
these of these impulse response
measurements and as long as those hit
all of the directions in RN then I can
essentially arbitrarily control this
with that actuation input column vector
B okay which i think is pretty pretty
neat okay and this is actually what you
would do in a real experiment so most
experiments of a physical system maybe
there is some continuous-time dynamics
but in practice what you do is you
measure it at a fixed delta T in time so
you actually collect data more like this
and so if you stacked it into a matrix
you could essentially see which
directions in RN are reached by an
impulse in in your in your system okay I
still haven't shown you how this
directly ties to this matrix for the
continuous-time system but I just wanted
to give you this analogy of the impulse
response in discrete-time and
essentially how this gives you an idea
that the states that are reachable with
control are going to be in this subspace
okay thank you